besorgen sie sich jeweils auch dieses
heft oder blättern beim zahnarzt ein
bisschen drin
seit 30 jahren veröffentlicht das
schweizer wirtschaftsmagazin bilanz zum
jahresende eine rangliste der 300
reichsten mit wohnsitz in der schweiz
und liechtenstein und es verkauft sich
jeweils die warme semmeln reichtum
fasziniert ganz offensichtlich und
irritiert zugleich faszination oder
irritation darüber sprechen wir jetzt
schon sind sie dabei
bei mir zu gast sind karin stüber sieht
verwaltungsratspräsidentin der
mercedes-benz automobile ag und
titularprofessor in für
sprachwissenschaft an der universität
zürich um zu gast ist christian
neuhäuser professor für philosophie an
der technischen universität dortmund und
bei uns ist auch markus huppenbauer
professor für ethik an der universität
zürich
herzlich willkommen schön sind sie da ja
frau stüber sie sind in diesem heft zu
finden gehören also zu den 300 reichsten
der schweiz die bilanz gibt ihr vermögen
an mit 1 bis 1,5 milliarden schweizer
franken das reicht nicht ganz für die
top ten sind sie dennoch zufrieden
ja also zufriedener auf jeden fall ich
muss ehrlich sagen dass ich in diesem
heft drin bin das bedeutet mir jetzt
nicht nicht die welt ich habe mich nicht
da jetzt die auch lange drauf gefreut
dass ich es vielleicht irgendwann hier
ins heft schaffe man muss auch sagen wir
sind als familie da drin also das ist
das vermögen der ganzen familie das sind
nicht mein eigenes und das bedeutet mir
natürlich schon sehr viel in diese
familie hineingeboren zu sein ist ein
großes privileg natürlich ist für mich
aber auch eine verpflichtung der familie
gegenüber
darüber sprechen die gleiche für mich
noch dafür interessieren wie hat man
eigentlich irgendwie benachrichtigt dass
man in diesem herbst kommt man wird
bevor auf das was kommt ein journalist
vorbei denn mein vater jetzt seit vielen
jahren kennt und ich jetzt dieses jahr
zum ersten mal kennen lernen durfte also
das ist abgesprochen was da drin steht
haben sie vorhin von dieser
verpflichtung gesprochen das sah man sie
auch immer wieder dass sie reich zu sein
auch eine verantwortung bedeutet
tatsächlich haben sie ja auch ihre
professur für sprachen
wissenschaft an der universität würzburg
quasi zurückgegeben und eben diese
verantwortung für das unternehmen
übernommen sich sehen stehen heute an
der spezial des familienbetriebs mit
2300 mitarbeitenden und haben noch eine
titularprofessor an der universität
zürich
wem gegenüber genau fühlen sie sich denn
verantwortlich oder verpflichtet er
einerseits natürlich schon der familie
also mein vater hat er das aufgebaut hat
meiner schwester und auch der nächsten
generation und ich habe selber keine
kinder aber ich habe zwei nichten und
die idee wäre schon dass auch diese
nächste generation einmal profitieren
darauf aber natürlich auch eben unser
vermögen da steckt ja nicht einfach in
bankkonten oder in einem aktienportfolio
sondern in ein in diesem unternehmen und
diesem unternehmen gegenüber denke das
ist die hauptverantwortung diesen
mitarbeitern gegenüber die auch alle
familie haben das sind sehr viele
personen deren wohlergehen auch davon
abhängt ob es unser unternehmen eben gut
geht oder nicht
sie herr huppenbauer habe ich nicht
gefunden in der bilanz sondernummer
obwohl ich von ihnen weiß dass sie
durchaus gerne mal richtig schön essen
gehen und auch mal eine teure flasche
wein zu sich nehmen würden sie gerne in
diesem heft stehen und zu den 300
reichsten gehen
es ist nichts was ich anstreben würde
ich glaube man kann es auch nicht wählen
und ich muss auch sagen wenn ich die
wahl hätte ich glaube ich würde nein
sagen einfach deswegen weil ich mit der
situation in der ökonomisch auch sozial
bin in universitäts professor an einer
der besten universitäten der welt ich
bin einfach zufrieden ich krieg mehr als
genug geld um vernünftig zu leben also
nicht aber ich würde diese möglichkeit
uplink zumal sie auch mit sehr sehr
vielen verantwortlichkeiten verbunden
ist wenn man reich eben nicht einfach
nur versteht also ich mache jetzt jux
und tollerei sondern wirklich auch auf
eine verantwortung versteht das klingt
jetzt was das müsste man die reichen ein
bisschen bemitleiden ein bemitleiden
muss man sie nicht das war ja auch keine
beschreibung es gibt bestimmt sehr viele
reiche die relativ nachlässig und mit
mit ihrer verantwortung geben aber es
gibt andere wird gerade im zusammenhang
mit familienunternehmen die nehmen ihre
verantwortung wirklich war
die haben in unternehmen investiert
schauen für die angestellten bezahlen an
stellen die steuern spenden
auch anständig also das machen einige
schon und das gutzumachen auf eine gute
weise zu machen und auch dabei zu achten
dass der eigene charakter dabei nicht
wirklich verloren geht das ist schon
eine ambitionierte die sache dann nicken
sie herr neuhäuser was für sie wäre es
ja eigentlich fast ein bisschen ruf
schädigen sie stünden in dem heft wobei
man auch sagen muss das wäre auch gar
nicht möglich weil sie nämlich in
deutschland leben aber trotzdem in
seinem heft zu stehen wäre ein problem
denn sie schreiben bücher mit titeln wie
reichtum aus moralisches problem oder
wie raich darf man sein über gier neid
und gerechtigkeit und eines ist völlig
klar sie finden reichtum ein problem
sollte es also solche hefte in einer
idealen welt gar nicht geben
ja ich kannte dieses heft ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht ob es jetzt dieses heft geben
sollte oder nicht egal
die frage ist ja ob das hat kein
gegenstand haben sollte also ob es
niemanden geben sollte er in diesem heft
stehen kann und ich glaube tatsächlich
dass in einer idealen welt das so nicht
wäre
es gebe auch in einer idealen welt
menschen die mehr geld hätten als andere
aber ich denke nicht so viel mehr geld
als der durchschnitt der bevölkerung
und das ist tatsächlich position die ich
vertrete und mir wurde bevor ich
angefangen habe dazu zu publizieren auch
gesagt dass bestimmte lebenschancen für
mich sich dadurch nicht mehr realisieren
lassen den ich selber reich zu werden
weil ich mich dann unglaubwürdig mache
und das war ziemlich kleine risiko wie
ich dann doch habe ich dann doch in kauf
genommen aber es wäre auch ein risiko
für sie das heißt sie fände es attraktiv
reich zu werden
aber wenn es doch irgendwie in amerika
ein erpel gebe
von dem noch nichts weiß er dann
plötzlich bekam ich den brief dann hätte
ich erst mal ein problem mit dem ich
umgehen müsste ja und wenn es dann zum
beispiel in den usa pflichtanteil gebe
und dass dann in den usa einem
unternehmen stecken würde hätte ich
tatsächlich auch ein ernsthaftes
moralisches problem also die sache ist
nicht einfach das will ich auch sagen
das ist moralisches problem man muss man
darüber nachdenken aber es ist jetzt
nicht so dass es irgendwie eine ganz
einfache lösung
interessant ist ja an solchen listen das
jetzt nicht nur auf die schweiz bezogen
existenz und um zb die forbes-liste der
reichsten ist eine sehr berühmte liste
dies auch schon lange gibt ich habe
schon gesagt dass bilanz sondern magazin
kommt seit fast 30 jahren heraus und
ursprünglich war tatsächlich die idee
mehr transparenz zu schaffen
über die machtverhältnisse auch die eben
irgendwie auch korrelieren mit reichtum
darüber werden wir später noch sprechen
es würde mich interessieren von ihnen
noch zu hören wie begegnet man ihnen
denn ich habe am anfang ja gesagt es
gibt faszination und irritation es gibt
auch bezüglich dieses heftes ein stück
weit war lloris muss man gelegen die
wissen der hier drin steht die nehmen
sie das selber raus vermögende personen
ja also ich muss jetzt ehrlich sagen
dass ich persönlich eben wirklich zum
ersten mal in diesem heft stehe und es
ist ja noch nicht so lange zeit
herausgekommen ist darauf wurde ich
jetzt tatsächlich noch nicht
angesprochen ich wurde so ein artikel
von uns über meinen vater und mich in
der bilanz im september da wirklich sehr
sehr viel liter auf angesprochen aber
ich denke auch dass der artikel über uns
in diesem heft relativ sympathisch
rüberkommt und also ich habe jetzt nie
negative reaktion aber vielleicht die
leute die das stört die werden mich
vielleicht auch nicht drauf ansprechen
ich meinte jetzt auch gar nicht nur dass
in diesem heft stehen sondern generell
wie nimmt man reichtum eigentlich war
haben sie das gefühl menschen begegnen
ihnen anders wie vielleicht personen
ich habe jetzt in der stadt ein schönes
essen hat aber nicht erreichen
ich habe erstaunlich viele positive
reaktionen bekommen als viele leute
gerade an der uni ich hoffe ja auch an
der uni zürich tätig und die meisten
wussten das nicht weil ich das nicht an
die große glocke gehängt habe und ich
habe jetzt aber eignen sich sehr viele
positive reaktionen bekommen auch
über diese entscheidung dass ich eben
die professur aufgeben und zurückkomme
und das unternehmen weiterführt das hat
doch auch da ist man mit achtung
begegnet uns nicht auch damit
zusammenhängen dass die wirklich sehr
reichen obwohl jetzt eine neben mir
sitzt in der regel für uns normal so
weit weg sind dass wir dass wir gar
keine vergleichsmöglichkeiten haben dass
wir vergleichen uns auch nicht mit den
sie erreichen das ist dann wie ein
exotisches land irgendwo ganz weit weg
und mir gar nicht zugänglich
gelegentlich trifft man jemanden aber es
ist nicht das was für mich in meinem
leben wirklich relevant ist und insofern
halte ich dieses heft auch also jetzt
sozusagen von der vom wirtschaftlichen
informationsgehalt er ist nett das zu
wissen aber wirklich entscheidend ist es
ja nicht das ist im wesentlichen meinen
augen marketing
die meisten schweizer schweizerinnen die
vergleichen sich ja auch nicht mit
solchen menschen sondern die vergleichen
sich mit den leuten die gleichung
bereich sind gleichzeitig ist natürlich
auch so ein sehnsuchtsort die
superreichen und gerade in den usa hat
man auch ein sehr viel positiveres bild
der reichen der vermögenden zum teil
zumindest weil man vielleicht diese
tellerwäscher idee hat diese idee dass
man die tellerwäscher karriere geschafft
und auch noch ganz reich werden könnte
tatsache ist auf jeden fall dass die
schweizer superreichen auf ein
einträgliches jahr zurückblicken
allein die zehn vermögendsten des landes
konnten ihr vermögen um 4 prozent
steigern und besitzen zusammen jetzt 700
2 milliarden franken
eine rekordzeit das magazin bilanz diese
liste der 300 reichsten herausgibt
es ging steil nach oben in diesem jahr
mit dem goldpreis mit den aktien und
deshalb auch mit dem vermögen der
reichsten
platz herrscht seit jahren ist die ikea
familie kamprad den konzern lenken die
drei brüder jonas peter und matthias
kamprad alle drei haben den schweizer
pass ihr vermögen gut 54 milliarden
franken
platz zwei die roche erben familie
hoffmann chef des clans und
vizepräsident des konzerns ist andre
hoffmann familienvermögen 28 milliarden
franken
platz drei ein verschwiegener
luxuskonzern in den händen der gebrüder
wertheim gerrard wertheimer wohnt in
genf vermögen 23 milliarden franken
eine spezielle klasse der superreichen
sind die manager sie haben weder geerbt
noch aufgebaut sie haben nur verdient
millionen verdient neu in der liste sind
die top manager sergio ermotti über es
walter kielholz swiss re und paul bulcke
nestlé alle drei mit einem vermögen von
100 bis 150 millionen franken
allgemein hatten die reichsten des
landes allen grund zum feiern in diesem
jahr allen grund zum feiern in diesem
jahr für die philosophie nicht unbedingt
sagen sie vielleicht eher einen grund zu
klagen
sie sagen ja die reichen werden zwar
immer reichen aber das ist eigentlich
ein problem und sie zielen nicht auf die
einzelnen superreichen und sagen die
sind das problem sondern sie halten die
struktur dahinter für ein problem warum
die die zahlen sind sehr eindeutig die
knapp 30 reichsten menschen der welt
besitzen ungefähr so viel wie die hälfte
der weltbevölkerung das muss man sich
einfach mal klar machen dass ist
wirklich enorm an reichtum der einen
sehr wenigen händen sehr stark
konzentriert ist dass sich die ganz kurz
unterbrechen das gleich darstellen weil
das haben wir nämlich genauso auch
geplant und ich möchte das ganz kurz
zeigen und dann sprechen sie weiter wir
haben hier ein bisschen geld natürlich
kein echtes geld muss sich zugunsten der
nationalbank eher wenig genau
also hier verschiedene bündeln wir haben
so aufgegliedert dass wir gesagt haben
welt vermögen das gehört zehn prozent
der menschheit das gehört den restlichen
90 dem entscheiden
das könnte vielleicht so ein bisschen
anschaulich das ganze noch einmal zeigen
dir gehören zu den 90 zu den zu den 90
prozentigen dass sie gehört die
reichsten besitzen das hier und jetzt
geht es weiter
und das scheint mit hat sich auch das
problem zu sagen nicht dass einzelne
reiche menschen vielleicht gerne feiern
das also wer feiern möchte so feiern und
es gibt tatsächlich nicht das heißt es
ja auch reichtum als mehr als problem
und nicht die reichen als moralisches
problem gewissermaßen und ich glaube
dass es drei probleme sind die damit
verbunden sind es gibt ein politisches
problem der einfluss der politische
einfluss der reichen als gruppe der
zunehmend größer es gibt ein
ökonomisches problem
eigentlich ist die republikanische idee
dass auch die menschen gemeinsam darüber
entscheiden wie gewirtschaftet wird wie
wir beispielsweise mit dem klimawandel
umgehen und das ist nicht der fall
sondern es ist so dass das also etwas
gibt wie eine strukturelle reichtums
orientierung die dafür sorgt dass wir
ein wirtschaftssystem geschaffen haben
das darauf angewiesen ist dass immer
mehr reichtum produziert wird und dass
es mit sachen wie bewältigung des
klimawandels einfach nicht vereinbar
und ich selber denke es gibt noch ein
drittes problem und dadurch auch ein
bisschen widersprechen dass es zwar so
ist dass sich menschen erst mal
vergleichen mit menschen aus ihrem
unmittelbaren umfeld aber immer so ein
bisschen nach oben
und dann gibt es nun kaskadeneffekt ist
das immer eine stufe weiter nach oben
geht und das gibt so eine orientierung
das strukturell alle menschen ein
bisschen mehr haben wollen und das ist
tatsächlich auch ein problem weil dann
etwas starke passiert was wir glaube ich
auch in ländern wie der schweiz oder
deutschland sehen dass wir mit status
kämpfen konfrontiert sind und menschen
zeigen wollen dass sie in sozialen
status haben über den sie signalisieren
dass sie dazugehören
jetzt haben wir eine ganze palette an
argumenten vielleicht beginnen wir
gleich mit dem ersten nämlich der
politischen einflussnahme das ist
tatsächlich ein thema das sie sehr
beschäftigt die bringen zum beispiel die
koch brüder aus beispiel die den
wahlkampf von der tram unterstützt haben
mit ich glaube 400 millionen wenn ich es
richtig im kopf habe und sagen das ist
dann eigentlich demokratie mehr stimmt
das ja genau ich neige dazu zu sagen
nein es ist kein wirkliches problem all
die demokraten klicken ja genau so viel
also die kohle ist auf beiden seiten gut
verteilt in amerika könnte das problem
eher darin bestehen dass die politisch
mächtigen elite unterdessen sind das
alles sehr reiche menschen also die
haben einfach von ihrer lebenswelt hier
keinen bezug mehr zu den weniger reichen
ich glaube auch dass man aufpassen muss
mit pauschalurteilen sind vom weltweit
ist es so wir müssen auch immer wieder
die länder anschauen und es scheint sie
sind hier in der schweiz
und ich habe den eindruck natürlich gibt
es in der schweiz sehr viel dampf
kräftige lobbys es gibt sehr reiche
menschen die die politik beeinflussen
allerdings besorgt mich das nicht so
sehe also ich finde wir sind sehr viel
mehr transparenz haben aus wie es heute
haben dass das würde ich sofort
zugeschrieben aber insgesamt wenn wir in
den letzten jahren schauen
ich habe nicht den eindruck dass in der
schweiz die sehr reichen finanzkräftigen
gruppen über gebühr einfluss ausgeübt
haben warum ist das so weil wir
politische strukturen haben weil wir
sechs und balances haben die das eben
verhindern dass beispielsweise ein
blocher über die svp alles dominieren
kann aber die politischen strukturen
sind relevant und offensichtlich rahmen
wird in den vereinigen staaten nicht
mehr
ja ich glaube nicht dass das stimmt also
ich glaube dass es tatsächlich stimmt
dass die situation in den usa sehr viel
plakativer ist und dass daran liegt dass
es eben vor allen dingen individuelle
reiche akteure sind die dann auch direkt
als politische akteure auftreten
abgeordnetenhaus gibt es nicht so viel
repräsentantenhaus gibt es nicht so
viele leute die nicht der bereich sind
man kann nicht präsident oder
präsidentin lernen dass die demokraten
auch viel geld bekommen scheint mir aber
teil des problems zu sein weil das
bestimmte politik option auch für die
demokraten unmöglich macht die sind
darauf angewiesen für ihre wahlkämpfe
sehr sehr viel geld
einzufangen und obama hat dann nach dem
ende seiner amtszeit auch gesagt dass er
sehr viele sachen nicht machen konnte
weil darauf angewiesen war finanziert zu
werden
das leuchtet mir also alles ein ich
glaube dass es tatsächlich so ist dass
wir in europa nicht solch eine lange
haben also wir haben nicht so ein neo
oligarch isches neo römisches system wir
haben viel bessere checks and balances
wir verhindern dass sozusagen
individuelle reichere direkt politische
macht ausüben aber strukturell habe ich
schon den eindruck dass zunimmt
problemen steht über die medien die sehr
stark jetzt doch auch zunehmend
privatisiert kontrolliert werden von
großen medienkonzernen also da wird sehr
viel öffentlichkeit er produziert es
gibt sehr viele folgen von lobbyismus
und das wichtigste finde ich eigentlich
es gibt eine art der passiven
machtausübung ja als politiker als
politikerin ist das so dass man schon
sich fragt okay wie kommt das eigentlich
beim reichtum an was wir politisch
vorhaben und dann müssen die gar nicht
mehr intervenieren sonst leicht dann
schon dazu nicht ich würde gerne mal
frau schuss rauscht über fragen sie sind
schweizerin ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus
dass sie auch begeistert sind von der
schweizer demokratie sind die meisten
schweizer und schweizerinnen würden sie
eine partei finanzieren oder sich ein
medienhaus kaufen
sie könnten ja extrem viel politisch
einfluss nehmen ja aber nein das würde
ich auch aus prinzip glaube ich nicht
tun also ich würde schon eine partei in
einem gewissen rahmen unterstützen oder
vielleicht auch mal eine kampagne wenn
wir etwas wichtig ist aber ich würde
nicht versuchen wolle neben über die
kontrolle zum beispiel von medien da
wesentlichen einfluss zu nehmen hat
vielleicht auch damit zu tun dass ich
nicht so politisch interessiert und
engagiert fehlen aber ich sehe ich sehe
das problem dass er nach hause und
spricht schon also ich das ist sehr
problematisch wenn ja wenn man durch
geld dann politischen einfluss sich
sozusagen erkaufen kann das ziemlich
interessant dass ich das jetzt sagen das
ist ja auch so dass wenn man die
oecd-kriterien anschaut für die qualität
einer demokratie dann gehört da zum
beispiel dazu
dass man die parteienfinanzierung
offenlegt dafür wird die schweiz zum
beispiel ja immer wieder geübt dass wir
das nicht tun
also insofern scheint es ja ganz
offensichtlich von politischer brisanz
zu sein wenn sie erreiche sich der
heimischen herpen bauer ja und deswegen
würde ich habe ich vorhin auch gefordert
wir brauchen unbedingt mehr transparenz
ich teile trotzdem ihre an sich nicht
ganz dass er nochmal die schweiz es gibt
da sehr viele mächtige leute reiche
leute die einfluss nähmen
aber ich glaube man kann politische
designs so stricken dass dieser einfluss
reduziert wird das in der schweiz haben
wir beispielsweise jeder also jeder
akteur in der schweiz weiss jeder zeit
die der gegner kam eine initiative
starten und das relativ leicht gemacht
es gibt referent von daher glaube ich
auch sehr einflussreiche leute haben ihn
immer im hinterkopf
es gibt den politischen gegner der mich
jederzeit stoppen kann
weil das schweizer stimmvolk auch nicht
so leicht auszurechnen ist auch insofern
ich teile ihre aussagen bezüglich den
vereinigten staaten das ist nicht das
thema heute in der schweiz glaube ich
haben wir tatsächlich möglichkeiten
gefunden
mit diesem problem einigermaßen
vernünftig umzugehen man müsste sich
vielleicht überlegen geht das in einem
kleinen räumten start wie der schweiz
und sich auch relativ nah es ist doch
schon auf nur auf deutschland
übertragbar das weiß ich nicht
vielleicht können wir da auch ganz kurz
mal etwas noch sagen zum thema
ungleichheit weil das ja auch jetzt
immer so im raum steht in den usa die
ungleichheit vielleicht größer als in
der schweiz
es ist schwierig die ungleichheit
innerhalb eines landes überhaupt zu
messen oder zu beziffern meistens wir
bezug genommen auf diesen sogenannten
gini koeffizienten mit dem man diese
ungleichheit misst und meistens bezieht
sich der nur auf die messung von
einkommensunterschieden und da steht die
schweiz im vergleich mit anderen staaten
relativ gut oder durchschnittlich da die
einkommensverhältnisse in der schweiz
sind jetzt nicht extrem eklatant
unterschiedlich hingegen wenn man die
vermögensunterschiede anschaut dann
steht die schweiz nicht besonders gut
aus und dann im vergleich zu anderen
ländern gerade eigentlich nicht
besonders gut einige sagen ana jahren
und das mist ist zb ein problem das in
der schweiz die ahv und die zweite und
dritte säule nicht zum vermögen dazu
gerechnet werden das macht die schere
größer aber dennoch können wir
festhalten vermögensunterschiede in der
schweiz sind relativ groß und ich habe
auf facebook gefragt was die leute
eigentlich interessiert am thema reicht
und da kam eine frage die fand ich
interessant die man hat mir nicht
gefragt wie ist das eigentlich wenn man
vermögend ist stört einen dann diese
ungleichheit oder findet man die
eigentlich sogar attraktiv oder ist in
einem die egal
oder wie steht man zur ungleichheit also
ich denke attraktiv findet man isst man
sie nicht also es wäre schön in einer
welt zu leben wo alle so viel hätten wie
ich habe es geht mir ging mir eigentlich
nie darum dass ich mehr haben will alles
andere also dass die gibt es natürlich
auch das weiß ich aber so bin ich auch
nicht erzogen also ich finde es sehr
wichtig dass man auch zufrieden sein
kann mit dem was man hat und ich glaube
in der schweiz haben viele menschen die
auch wenn es jetzt nicht ausreicht
gelten dann haben dann dürfen sie
zufrieden sein mit dem was sie haben
ich denke die ungleichheit ist schon ein
problem und wir müssen aufpassen das
sind dass sie nicht größer wird also ich
finde es durchaus richtig dass man eben
progressive steuern schaut auch dass gut
verdienende mehr zu arbeiten als die
weniger gut verdienenden also ich denke
es für den sozialen zusammenhalt ist ist
das sehr essenziell dass die
unterschiede nicht zu groß werden sie
haben einmal gesagt dass sie selber
dafür besorgt sind reichtum nicht zur
schau zu stellen weil sie glauben
reichtum kann zum sozialen spaltpilz
werden denn die reichen sozusagen
trotzen was willst du sie heißen
reichtum zur schau zu stellen
es kommt natürlich sehr auf den kontext
darauf an aber mir kommt dann immer in
den zähnen letztes jahr war ich in
kapstadt und ich mal niemand von uns
möchte in einem slum in kapstadt leben
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen was ich dann
die schönen willen gesehen habe die aber
hohe mauern rund um herum haben mit
stacheldraht bewehrt sind und mit
kameras
ich möchte dort auch nicht leben also
dort haben wir dann wirklich die
situation es gibt auch substanzielle aus
existenzieller armut und die
unterschiede sind riesig und dann ist
wird es zum problem wenn man eben so ein
schönes haus hat das ist dass wir zum
stein des anstoßes
ich denke man könnte wahrscheinlich auch
in der schweiz
genug großes anwesen haben dass man das
dann bewachen lassen muss und und eben
sonst kommt das denke ich sehr auf den
kontext erfahren als ich in würzburg
professorin war hab ich ja ein relativ
kleines auto gefahren weil ich mich doch
nicht herausheben wollte aus der
professorenschaft und jetzt aus
verwaltungsratspräsidentin eines
autohandels gar nichts mehr reißen denke
ich etwas größeren zuvor
ich glaube wenn jetzt über slum in
kapstadt sprechen da für dich gerne
jetzt auch mal übergehen zu ihrer
kernthese herr neuhäuser sie sagen ja
das problem an reichtum ist dass er die
würde des menschen verletzt
jetzt wenn ihr dieses beispiel nehmen
das rauscht über gerade gehabt gebracht
hat dann leuchtet das ja unmittelbar ein
das sind menschen in slums die haben
vielleicht keine toilette die müssen
vielleicht betteln gehen möglicherweise
die mülltonnen durchsuchen um etwas
essbares zu finden
man versteht sofort extreme armut kann
die würde von menschen verletzen und
reichtum entsprechend auch ein problem
sein
jetzt kommen wir zurück in die schweizer
wollen heute vor allem auch über
reichtum bei uns sprechen dann fragt man
sich wie sollen die ihre these verstehen
warum soll hier reichtum zb meine würde
verletzen
also es ist natürlich so dass ich mit
meiner these in der schweiz den
schwersten stand weltweit habe
wahrscheinlich weil man die schweiz ist
wahrscheinlich die letzte echte republik
die wir haben und wenn die menschen
tatsächlich republikanische
selbstverständnis haben dann ist das so
dass diese politischen probleme weniger
auftreten als in andern ländern das
scheint mir ganz klar zu sein weil dann
im reich sein er bedeutet politisch
verpflichtet zu sein dass nicht zu
missbrauchen das gehört zum
republikanischen verständnis dazu und in
der schweiz kann man sich vielleicht ein
bisschen darauf verlassen dass die
meisten das auch so sehen einen anderen
ländern vielleicht ist das mit dem
republikanischen geistern nicht so stark
der fall
was jetzt die würde angeht da würde ich
denken dass es so ist dass es in jedem
land auch in der schweiz so etwas gibt
wie eine normalität vorstellung was man
haben muss um in der gesellschaft
dazuzugehören
das ist eine ganz alte these die sich
übrigens schon bei dem erz liberalen dem
smith findet er gesagt hat man brauchen
leinenhemd und lederschuhe und sie auf
die straße trauen zu können und solche
sachen sind es gehört heute natürlich
auch in handys gehört dazu empfehlen
das regt ja immer leute auf die
sozialhilfe schimpfen aber es geht genau
um die um die sozusagen zugehörigkeit
zur gesellschaft damit ich damit machen
kann genau und das sind wichtige sachen
und dann zu jemandem zu sagen ja wieso
hast du ein handy gibt es nicht ganz
viel wichtigere sachen für die du deinen
wenig geld ausgeben muss ist in dem
sinne und verwalten handy besitzen
gerade bei jungen leuten einfach
dazugehört wenn man das nicht hat dann
wie soll man mit den leuten
kommunizieren die zettel und dann ist
das so dass ich glaube dass auch in der
schweiz die ungleichheit inzwischen so
groß ist dass es sehr viele menschen
gibt die inzwischen täglich signalisiert
bekommen dass sie nicht dazu gehören ich
selber habe eine weile in luzern gelebt
und da ist es so dass in dem ja sogar
größeren kern der innenstadt ist dass
die wohnungspreise 1
ein ausmaß angenommen hatten das sehr
sehr viele menschen die dort leben und
arbeiten wollen es sich nicht leisten
können dort zu leben und sie wieder noch
verdrängen jetzt habe ich meine wieso
muss man sagen das verletzt die würde
kann man das sagen na ja so ist es halt
man muss ja deswegen nicht auf der
straße kampieren sondern man kann 1 vor
ort ziehen
also ich verstehe eigentlich den würde
begriff in dem zusammenhang auch nicht
wirklich
ich habe auch den eindruck dass viele
leute von denen sie reden sich gar nicht
in ihrer würde verletzt fühlen auch
gerade in der schweiz also ich will hier
verhält ist ja nicht schön wir können
gerne auch über die negativen folgen
reichtum reden ich glaube das ist das
relevante ich glaube die schweizer haben
dann keine schweizerinnen haben dann
keine mühe mädels großen ungleichheiten
auch wenn sie selbst gar nicht so viel
habe ich den eindruck haben die sozialen
schichten sind einigermaßen durchlässig
das heißt ich habe als junger mensch
doch irgendwie eine chance mehr zu
verdienen und das ist in der schweiz
extrem gut gegeben über die
durchlässigkeit des bildungssystems ich
glaube das ist ein punkt also wir haben
eine gymnasial quote aktivitäten von 20
prozent aber insgesamt von 40 prozent dh
die hälfte der menschen die natur haben
der schweiz gegen nicht über das
gymnasium dh sie haben andere wege
wir wollten sich zu bilden damit mehr zu
verdienen das heißt durchlässigkeit dann
habe ich nichts gegen ungleichheit
zweiter punkt wenn ich mitreden kann
wenn ich mitbestimmen kann
also wenn ich wie in frankreich die
gelb-weißen irgendwie den eindruck haben
da sitzt in paris die reiche politische
elite die diktiert mir der benzinpreise
in der provence habe ich mühe damit
aber wir haben jederzeit die möglichkeit
mitzubestimmen über initiativen und
referenden und ich glaube dann ist für
den einzelnen auch wenn jetzt nicht
vergleichen mit statussymbolen sind die
unterschiede nicht gar so dramatisch
aber vielleicht kann ich das beispiel
noch meinem aufnehmen von vom wohnraum
ich meine das ist ja wirklich ein thema
das beschäftigt die schweiz sehr zürich
ist auch so eine stadt da werden die
wohnungsmieten immer teurer
eine familie die jetzt nicht groß geerbt
hat kann sich zum beispiel auch den kauf
einer wohnung oder eines hauses sind
zürich absolut nicht mehr leisten aber
das ist doch kein wörter problem
doch es ist kein problem der
menschenwürde kein problem der personen
würde es ist nicht so dass man darin
gehindert wird eine sich eine eigene
vorstellung vom guten leben zu machen
und die sondern ist es so dass man darin
gehindert wird seine eigene vorstellung
vom guten leben in der gesellschaft in
der man lebt verfolgen zu können
und da will ich halt sagen es gab mal in
deutschland und ich denke auch der
schweiz den grundkonsens dass man wenn
man arbeitet und wenn man fleißig ist
man da wo man arbeitet und lebt sich
auch eine wohnung leisten kann und dass
es so ist dass das dass die
unterschiedlich groß und bescheiden
ausfallen kann das hängt von vielen
faktoren habe wie viel man geleistet hat
vielleicht auch ein bisschen glück
vielleicht ein bisschen erfolg aber das
war so die grundidee und die bricht weg
die bricht vollkommen weg in deutschland
in den meisten großen städten über 500
1000 einwohnerinnen
die müssen da wegziehen das ist
natürlich mit sehr großen kosten
verbunden wir wissen zum beispiel dass
mehr als eine halbe stunde pendeln dazu
führt dass die lebensqualität enorm
sinken das nehmen die leute war
und die nehmen auch wahr dass sie da
eine wichtige lebenschance sind nicht
haben die andere
haben und das verletzten dem sind die
persönliche würde dass sie den eindruck
haben dass ihre möglichkeit ihre
vorstellung vom guten leben realisieren
zu können nicht mehr so viel zählt wie
die andere
gleich müssen ja auch gar nicht mehr
noch lang ist das jetzt wirklich der
richtige begriff oder nicht wahr dass
ich ja noch einmal eine philosophische
debatte ich dass ich aber was sie ja
schon festhalten können dass das
beispiel was jetzt herr neuhaus erbringt
die verletzung des leistungsprinzips
dass sie sich nicht mehr lohnt sich
wirklich anzustrengen weil das was da
oben auf mich wartet ist nicht das was
ich wollte oder ich kann das mir nicht
erarbeiten was ich gerne möchte dass das
ein problem sein kann
finden sie das leistungsprinzip ist
unter druck jetzt durch diese einkommens
oder vermögens ja vielleicht bis zu
einem gewissen grad schon und immobilien
sind sind sicher eines der probleme aber
ich denke das ist es hängt ja sicher
nicht an den 300 reichsten die haben
nicht die brauchen nicht so vielen
wurden platz
dass das zum problem wird und ich denke
ein problem ist wirklich sind die
negativzinsen man man investiert in
immobilien und die werden immer mehr
wert das heißt wer hat dem wird gegeben
und das ist schon ein problem das der
das denke ich schon also dass dort
klafft die schere bei den vermögen
tatsächlich immer mehr auseinander
aber nicht weil die mehrheit muss vorher
sondern weil die einzelnen häuser und
grundstücke so viel mehr wert geworden
sind und dann kommt noch die frage des
erben sind zu weil das jetzt auch gerade
eine neue studie noch einmal gezeigt hat
dass sehr viel immobilien als anlage
attraktiv sind für menschen die eben
geerbt haben und vererbt wird in der
schweiz immer mehr auch in deutschland
man rechnet auch damit dass in den
folgenden generationen denn die baby
boomer jetzt erst einmal sterben dann
wird noch einmal sehr viel mehr vererbt
werden
sie selber haben wir auch ihr vermögen
eigentlich natürlich ein stück weit
haben sie auch schon dazu gearbeitet
aber auch geerbt schon ihr vater hat es
geerbt eigentlich war ihr großvater
derjenige der das große geld gemacht
habt ja das ist wie ist denn ihr
verhältnis dazu wenn man ihnen jetzt
sagt forscht über dieses geld gehört
ihnen doch gar nicht weil sie haben es
nicht erarbeitet was entgegnen sie
also ich sehe das schon ein bisschen zu
hause für mich ist es doch ein bisschen
eine leihgabe also ich würde mir jetzt
nicht das recht zu sprechen dass ich mit
diesem vermögen machen kann was ich will
dass ich es verschwenden kann mich ich
sehe mich verpflichtet dem sorge zu
tragen eben aber schon auch das auch für
eine nächste generation eben weiter sehe
ich glaube es ist ein grundbedürfnis des
menschen dass man der nächsten
generation etwas gibt also und man
möchte das ist ein ansatz wäre wieder
ihren kindern ja das ist den kindern
besser geht aus einem selbst ich denke
dass das ist ein wichtiges motiv für
viele und gerade natürlich eben dass man
natürlich das eigene haus weitergeben
wähler oder die eigene wohnung an
zugeben will dass das ist schon sehr
menschlich jetzt verstehe ich auch gut
dass gerechtigkeit die tische
perspektive ist es natürlich so dass der
effekt ist dass diejenigen die vererben
dann an ihre kinder
das weitergeben dass es den besser gehen
wird aber der negative preis ist dass
diejenigen die nichts erben dann nicht
nur nicht besser dastehen sondern
schlechter dastehen weil ihm sozusagen
die relativen vermögen sicher
konzentrieren
das glaube ich das tatsächlich der fall
und das bei so etwas wie dem
wohnungsmarkt etwas was wir sehr
deutlich sehen
unternehmen sind natürlich ein
spezieller fall ja und da muss man ganz
klar sagen dass diese tradition der
familienunternehmen eine ist gerade
nachdem sie ihre paternalistisches
gewarnt so ein bisschen abgestreift
haben und es nicht mit dem patriarchen
gibt was eigentlich für wirtschaften
sehr gut ist also für wirtschaftssysteme
wir sehen in der finanzkrise dass
diejenigen die große familienunternehmen
tradition hatten viel besser durch die
krise gekommen sind als andere weil da
eben genau diese werte orientierung da
ist die verantwortung das ist eine
wichtige sache und da gibt es glaube ich
aber in der erbschafts perspektive auch
lösungen für da zu sorgen dass man mit
kapital das sind unternehmen gebunden
ist anders umgeht als mit kapital das
gewissermaßen
dann nicht mehr auf indem sie eine
kapital sondern geldvermögen das den
konsum zugeführt das spricht ja nicht
unbedingt also dieser möglichen
negativen folgen oder tatsächlich
negativen folgen sprechen nämlich gegen
reich und per se sondern sie sprechen
für eine vernünftige ausgestaltung der
erbschaftsteuer für die ich persönlich
bin ich würde darf ich noch mal auf den
dänen verdienst zurückkommen
ich persönlich bin der ansicht dass
sowohl vererbte wie auch sogenannte
selbst arbeitete vermögen nie verdient
sind insofern dass man wirklich sein
kann es war genau diese leistung von mir
oder eine person die dann zu diesem
reichtum geführt hat gibt alle vermögen
sind unverdient und sind deswegen mit
bestimmten verpflichtungen verbunden wie
sie sie eben geschildert haben warum
sind alle vermögen um verdient natürlich
brauche ich als antrieb kann er
beispielsweise eine gute idee ich muss
opportunitäten wahrnehmen
ich muss große risiken eingehen zum teil
habe große verantwortungen auch aber
dass das ganze dann wirklich erfolg hat
das liegt überhaupt nicht in meinen
händen es hängt davon ab wo ich wohne
wie die aktienkurse sind abgaben
klimakatastrophe irgendwo ist eher
schwachen zwischen den beispiel sie
jetzt aufzählen und dem lottospielen ich
darüber letztlich nicht alles ist laut
nein ich würde ich sagen alles ist laut
ich würde sagen die vermögen sind die
großen vermögen sind nicht verdient sie
sind aber auch nicht unverdient war eben
bestimmte leistungen selbstverständlich
dahinter stehen nicht jeder kann
aufgrund seiner leistung zu einem
reichen menschen werden außer sie sind
nicht verdient aber auch sie sind auch
nicht unverdient das unterscheidet sie
von bord
prinzipiell sollten wir mit reichtum
genauso umgehen wie wir mit einem
lottogewinn umgehen nämlich ich habe
jetzt plötzlich mehr als viele andere
das ist mit verpflichtung warum also das
heißt dass ich würde gern noch wissen
was das heißt was ist mit sich das heißt
für mich also einige reichtum mit
verpflichtung verbunden heisst
beispielsweise ich muss das geld das ich
habe vernünftig investieren entweder in
eine eigene firma auf das ist
hoffentlich eine gute firma welche ein
anständiges produkt haben menschen
anständig haben
ich bezahle mit großer freude meine
großen steuern befürworte auch
öffentlich beispielsweise sehr
progressive steuern aus
ich spende ich glaube auch das gehört zu
den flächen es gibt eine reihe von
pflichten die mit reichtum verbunden
sind eben gerade weil er nicht verdient
es aber ich wehre mich dagegen zu
glauben dass wenn wir die reichen alle
nur herum zu fahren würden die armen
insgesamt höher gestellt werden ist das
ihre these das ist natürlich nicht meine
these aber sie liest sich ein bisschen
nein das ist nicht so dass ich denke das
ist eine billige umverteilung wir nehmen
den ein und geben es den anderen
tatsächlich spielt bei mir der
leistungsgedanke eine wichtige rolle und
zwar eine viel wichtigere als das jetzt
deutlich geworden ist weil ich auch
glaube dass reichtum letztlich nie
vollständig verdient ist sehr große
ökonomische ungleichheit aber dazu führt
dass es sehr viele menschen gibt die in
wahrheit sehr sehr viel leisten aber den
eindruck haben müssen dass es sich bei
ihnen nicht lohnt gar nicht lohnt dass
sie so viel leisten
denk mir ein pflegeberufe et cetera et
cetera ja dass menschen die sehr sehr
viel leisten und dann es gibt es jemand
anderen der verdient 2000 mal so viel
und da muss man sich schon fragen wie
kann man das erklären und dadurch wird
ein ganz viele menschen das signal
ausgesendet dass sich leistung nicht
mehr lohnt es lohnt sich nicht etwas
glaube einfach nicht dass das stimmt
natürlich bin ich mit ihnen der der
gleichen ansicht
wenn man die dinge so vergleicht und
über konkrete leistung miteinander
vergleicht dann ist die ganze sache
schief aber keine krankenpflege person
vergleicht ihre leistung und das was sie
verdient mit den ganz reichen
die findet vielleicht auch sehr schön
ich hätte ein bisschen mehr aber sie
vielleicht sich nicht mit den ganz
harten ich mir jetzt nicht sicher gerade
in krankenhäuser ist natürlich eklatant
wie pflegepersonen bezahlt werden und
die chefärzte gezahlt wenn gerade im
gesundheitswesen
ich glaube ein problem liegt auch darin
diesen fokus jetzt auf die ganz reichen
zu richten wenn wir eine gesellschaft
hätten in der es sehr große ökonomische
gleichheit gebe und dann gibt es 300
menschen die da irgendwie raus fallen
die sehr reich sind dass wir überhaupt
gar kein problem ja das wäre dann
irgendwie seltsam interessant man wüsste
gern warum ist das so wie leben die und
dann gibt es dieses magazin sowieso
popstars oder also die wenn dann so ein
bisschen ganze persönlichkeit latina
oder sowas ja das würde raus fall aber
was wir haben ist sozusagen so eine
exponentielle kurve die nach oben geht
und es gibt immer jemanden wenn man das
gefühl hat ja der verdient zehnmal so
viel wie ich arbeitete er zehn mal so
viel
und an jedem punkt in der gesellschaft
bis ganz oben ist man damit konfrontiert
und wir haben in eine struktur
geschaffen die so extrem
erfolgsorientiert ist dass dieser
gedanke ja aber leistung im sinne von
ich ich mache das weil ich mich
verantwortlich fühle dass ich die noch
lohnt das ist etwas was dadurch sehr
stark zurückgegangen haben sie vorhin
gesagt sie sind nicht naiv und sagen
einfach wir machen jetzt hier eine
umverteilung die einen sollen weniger
haben die anderen dann mehr
trotzdem sagen sie sich natürlich für
stärkere progressive steuern ja eine
stärkere progression
sie haben wohin auch gesagt sie sind für
progressive steuern finden sie die
progression in der schweiz genug hoch
oder wären sie dafür dass anzuheben da
müssten sie noch mehr steuern machen
keiner glauben aber ich frage dann doch
nach dem system ja aber ich denke sollte
seine grenze haben also bei mir ist ganz
klar ein spontan die schmerzgrenze
irgendwo bei 50 prozent
ich will man mehr als die hälfte von dem
was man verdient wieder hergeben muss
dann finde ich das kann ich das
irgendwie nicht ganz einsehen und das
andere ist auch im wenn die progression
zu stark ist dann kann es sein dass auch
diejenigen die eigentlich viel leisten
möchten sich dann immer so
also wenn ich jetzt statt 80% 100%
arbeite dann bekomme ich gleich für habe
ich am schluss gleich viel weil das
alles wieder aufgefressen wird
und ich denke solches auch muss noch in
jedem fall verhindern weil sonst
eigentlich nicht die leistung gebraucht
wird wie möglich wäre vielleicht noch
ganz kurz nachher würde ich gerne
weitergehen wie viel progression
schlagen sie vor
ja das hat kann ich es verstehen dass
sie sagt ja das kann ich gut verstehen
es gibt auch eine ökonomische theorie
die optimale steuer rate festlegt die
sagt dass und 70 wo dieser das lohnt
sich dann nicht mehr noch weiter zu
arbeiten punkte rein kommt und wo ist
dann sozusagen negative effekt hat weil
nicht mehr die anreize geschaffen werden
ich glaube das selber nicht das wäre
sozusagen eine sehr detaillierte
diskussion ich glaube ein langfristiges
ziel sollte sein dass es 100 prozent
steuer gibt 100 prozent satte 100 m
rücken sie bezahlen ja gerne steuern
bezahle wirklich gerne steuern ich höre
präsident heimische technik nicht 100
prozent bei uns ist auch unterschiedlich
der die progression ist auf der
bundesebene staats und gemeindesteuern
sind nicht ganz so progressiv ausgebaut
ich bin eher bei war derzeit über
genannt hat man sieht dass das problem
mit der progression wenn zwei zusammen
verdienen und dann dafür bestraft werden
das ist eigentlich das problem nicht nur
für einzelpersonen sondern gerade in
haushalten werden die die familien
bestraft durch eine zu starke
progression ja aber das ist vielleicht
nicht so sagt ja da könnte jetzt lange
drüben ich würde mittlere einkommen
entlasten und sagen diese kurve soll
relativ langen flach bleiben und dann
erst relativ spät sehr stark ansteigen
und ich würde auch sagen das ist nichts
was man jetzt in zwei jahren einführen
kann
das kann man sehr sehr langfristig
musste man das einführen schon klar eine
frage ist ja immer eben der reichtum dem
abgeben könnt ihr was macht man damit
und sie haben im vorfeld auch gesagt
wenn alles zum start geht dann ist
vielleicht auch die frage verteilt der
staat dann effizient und geht das alles
genug schnell eine andere möglichkeit
ist überfiel am kopi nachzudenken und
tatsächlich selbst einige auf ihn an
truppe immer mehr vermögende geben der
gesellschaft auch eine menge zurück
nämlich in form von stiftungen die sich
für das gemeinwohl einsetzen oder haus
mit szene die kunst oder sport fördern
einer von ihnen ist der berner hansjörg
wyss einer der reichsten schweizer
er hat mit seinem
medizinaltechnikunternehmen sind es
milliarden verdient und finanziert
großprojekte in wissenschaft und kultur
er stellt dafür aber auch bedingungen zb
dieses jahr in bern das kunstmuseum
eine der wichtigsten kulturinstitutionen
der stadt bern
es liegt an einer stark befahrenen
straße im stadtzentrum das museum möchte
mehr gegenwarts kunst ausstellen aber
der platz fehlt der plan den alten
grauen anbau hier im bild für viel geld
ersetzen
die stadt und der kanton würden sich
daran beteiligen und auch er der mit
zehn hansjörg wyss stellt 20 millionen
franken in aussicht aber er stellt
bedingungen er schreibt aus seinem
wohnsitz in den usa
falls ein neues museum entsteht ist eine
autofreie hodlerstrasse absolut
notwendig um den neuen zugang zum museum
großzügig gestalten zu können
das sehen einige kritisch die sp
grossrätin ursula marti hat nichts gegen
weniger autos aber mit der forderung des
mit zehn satz mühe zahlen im
öffentlichen raum gestellt das geht
nicht das finde ich das nicht
akzeptieren
der mäzen hansjörg wyss sein geld und
seine forderungen sind in der stadt bern
eine längere geschichte vor gut zehn
jahren stand bereits einmal ein anbau
zur debatte
damit sehen wollte dieses projekt hier
das kunstmuseum ein anderes am schluss
gab der mit zehn kein geld das projekt
war gestorben
anderes beispiel der universität bern
stellte hans jörg wie es letztes jahr
100 millionen franken in aussicht für
die erforschung des klimawandels
bedingung auch die universität und der
kanton bern müssen 100 millionen franken
einschiessen
der grossrat war einverstanden
allerdings auch da nicht ohne kritik
jetzt also die forderung nach einer
autofreien hodlerstrasse was sagt der
berner stadtpräsident dazu wie normal
punkt also gut ich kann mir das
vorstellen dass man etwas mehr hier
schöner museumsneubau macht dass das
vertrauen der vorstellung muss
miteinander bis machen und das
vorstellen also das wetter überrascht
nur noch irritiert sonderlich aus
eigenen wald gefunden macht er mit zehn
hansjörg wie sie in bern auch politik
mit seinem geld er schreibt kann man
auslegen wie man will
wenn man ein großes geld geschenkt gibt
und dann bedingungen stellt die die
ganzen bevölkerung und der stadt nutzen
bringen ist dass politik oder weitsicht
politik oder weitsicht herum
es ist politik zunächst einmal weiter in
dem speziellen fall um den öffentlichen
raum geht und da habe ich die bedenken
der spd politiker ist im frau matthäus
glaubt durchaus verstanden
der stadtpräsident hatte er so ein
bisschen abgewickelt ja ja verstehen
aber ich würde schon auch sagen
wunderbar wenn jemand so viel geld gibt
und ich finde die reichen sollten noch
sehr viel mehr geld für solche dinge
geben wo allerdings an die grenze sowie
bedingung stände für das muss wirklich
genau ausgehandelt werden und ich würde
sagen übergriffe oder eingriff in den
öffentlichen raum die sind dann schon
sehr genau anzuschauen
da habe ich auch eher skeptisch ihr
vater hat ja den fußballclub geht sie
immer sehr maßgeblich unterstützt aber
auch präsident der tonhalle in zürich
führen dieses
die tonhalle fahrt und vor allem auch
noch für einen chor den zürcher
singkreis glaube ich sing akademie ist
sehr wichtig haben sie den eindruck
damit immer auch irgendwie politisch
tätig zu sein weil sie könnten ja auch
was ganz anderes unterstützen
ja das könnte ich natürlich schauen aus
dass das sind persönliche vorlieben das
gebe ich zu aber auch du also ich wäre
da sehr vorsichtig möchte weder der
tonhalle noch das inga können wie zum
beispiel vorschreiben was sie fühlt
konzert aufzuführen haben natürlich kann
man vorschläge machen aber in der regel
geld gelangt er die tonhalle an und
sagen wir möchten das und das machen
würde dir helfen oder natürlich auch bei
dem projekt turnhalle markt da haben
viele private mitgeholfen dass dieses
provisorium möglich zu machen aber das
projekt kam natürlich
also ich finde das schon problematisch
wenn man zu viel versucht dann auf den
inhalt einfluss zu nehmen
georg von schnurbein der ist professor
für philanthropie studien an der
universität basel und hat ein interview
gegeben im vorfeld für esskultur dass
man online noch nachlesen kann er sagt
zb philanthropie ist wunderbar weil es
zb den pluralismus in einer gesellschaft
fördert weil die einen lieben sport die
anderen eben klassische musik vielleicht
dritte popmusik markante gleich sagen
dass eine effiziente art und weise
pluralismus zu fördern
das stimmt natürlich überhaupt nicht
genau das gegenteil ist der fall
es ist eine sehr kleine gruppe von
leuten die entscheiden was sozusagen
bezahlt wird und was nicht und in dem
ein spiel haben wir sehr genau gesehen
dass gesagt wurde
ich entscheide was der
gesamtgesellschaftlichen nutzen ist und
da gebe ich mein geld hin und dass es
weitsicht und da scheint mir genau das
problem zu liegen das halte ich für
undemokratisch und auch anti
republikanisch dass es dann eine kleine
gruppe von leute entscheiden kann was
sozusagen gesellschaftlich jetzt als
wertvoll angesehen wird und was nicht in
dem beispiel mit dem klimawandel ist das
natürlich so dass wir es alle irgendwie
sympathisch finden dass bei der uni bern
jetzt 200 millionen euro in die
erforschung des klimawandels
gesteckt werden wenn sich der mensch
aber stärker für sagen wir eine
bestimmte militärische technologie
interessiert hätte und gesagt hätte ich
geb 100 millionen euro für die
erforschung dieser kampfroboter und wenn
die stadt das auch machte dann würden
wir wahrscheinlich anders darüber
nachdenken aber die macht die ist
offensichtlich da auch die stadt hätte
es nicht gemacht mich dass in ungarn ist
es nicht ganz so toll wissen ich habe
mich interessiert in diesem ganzen
gespräch etwas
es gibt dann würde dieses diskussion die
sehr darf man dann philanthropen
überhaupt ins geschäft sozusagen reden
es gab die große debatte um den
australischen philosophen peter singer
der den musikproduzenten david gessen
kritisiert hat öffentlich von ein paar
jahren er hat die avery fisher hall im
lincoln center in new york
renovieren lassen für ich glaube 100
millionen dollar und die heißt heute
david geffen hall also man setzt sich
natürlich dann auch noch so ein mahnmal
und er wurde kritisiert von peter singer
war er gesagt hat naja du hättest für
dieses geld unglaublich viel gutes
bewirken können unglaublich viele
menschen aus der extremen armut setzen
stattdessen da so eine konzerthalle sie
ich sehe mir sich da und was gefällt
ihnen nicht nicht interessiert das schon
auch wie reagiert man darauf wenn man ja
auch sagen könnte wieso reden wir den
vermögenden rein was sie mit dem geld
tun währenddessen wir die wir ja alle
auch viel spenden könnten uns redet
keiner rein wer das dem
kaninchenzüchterverein gehen gegen oder
für die keine ahnung bekämpfung der
armut
wie reagieren die aus das würde ich auch
so sehen ich denke man hat schon ein
gewisses recht egal auf welcher stufe
man geld gibt wenn das eigene geld ist
zu entscheiden wofür man es gibt also
und das ist natürlich bis zu einem
gewissen grade zufällig war wofür man
sich interessiert auch wer vielleicht an
einem gelaunt und und ford vielleicht
baisinger muss man auch sagen da die
zahl letztlich gar nicht um diesen einen
filmproduzenten der sehr viel geld hat
singen würde sagen alle die hier am
tisch sitzen müssen sehr viel von ihrem
geld weg geben also das ziel nicht
direkt auf die ganz reichen und
bedingungen
das schenken ganz rein sondern sie ist
ein moralischer appell an alle die in
der reichen westlichen welt wo sehr viel
von ihrem geld zugunsten der armen
kranken und schwachen zu gehen ich würde
auch die idee nicht teilen dass das bei
uns tatsächlich egal ist was wir damit
machen sondern ich glaube als
moralphilosoph wird man tatsächlich
sagen alle müssen darüber nachdenken
wofür sie ihr geld geben
aber das ist dann tatsächlich eine
moralische frage und da kann auch drüber
reden natürlich und dann ist es so wenn
man eine person des öffentlichen lebens
ist scheint sie mir okay sein zu sein
öffentlich darüber zu reden
nehmen wir die bill & melinda gates
stiftung die jetzt wirklich sehr sehr
viel geld hat da finde ich das völlig in
ordnung dass öffentlich darüber geredet
wird wir was passiert mit dem geld und
das ok oder nicht weil das natürlich
auch massive strukturelle effekte hat es
so es gibt diese giving pledge gruppe
das sind im multi milliardäre in gruppe
von 50 leuten weltweit die gemeinsamen
setzen und überlegen wofür sie dieses
geld ausgeben wollen dass sie spenden
und das ist sehr sehr viel geld das ist
sozusagen ein spendenaufkommen mehr als
der ganze rest zusammen ja und da finde
ich schon dass man aus einem
demokratischen geist heraus sagen kann
ja aber ist das jetzt der richtige
wollte oder nicht es wäre besser dieses
geld stünde doch den staaten zur
verfügung
das ist natürlich auch ein problem dass
das wenn wir hören den staaten dann
denken wir sofort an so eine andere
kleine gruppe von leuten die jetzt
darüber entscheiden was mit dem geld
passiert und optisch besser damit
umgehen oder nicht ist eine andere frage
wenn man mich fragen würde würde ich
denken
dieses geld sollte sehr sehr viele
menschen in der gesellschaft zur
verfügung stehen und die sollten
gemeinsam darüber nachdenken wie sie es
dann wieder die ideale welt das ist die
ideale welt
ich würde gerne zum schluss noch ein
bisschen über tugend ethische
überlegungen mit ihnen
ins gespräch kommen es gibt ja dieses
argument dass man sagt naja diese ganze
diskussion über reichtum designer so
unterfüttert mit der idee diejenigen die
weniger haben sind ja nur neidisch sie
sagen dieser dieses argument des neides
ist ein ideologisches abonnenten warum
weil meiner meinung nach hat sozusagen
jemand sein neidisch bedeutet dass
dieser mensch das haben möchte was
jemand anderes haben will
nur weil der andere das hat und das muss
man überprüfen ob das stimmt oder nicht
es kann sagen dass er gute gründe dafür
hat das haben zu wollen zum beispiel
fall denke er hätte das auch verdient
ja also wenn eine frau dasselbe
verdienen möchte wie ein mann in dem
selben beruf dann ist das nicht so dass
ich das aus neid möchte sondern sie
möchte das weil sie aus
gerechtigkeitsgründen denkt dass man für
gleiche arbeit gleiches geld bekommen
sollte und an so einer stelle zu sagen
ja das ist doch jetzt neidisch
du hast doch auch genug scheint mir
ungerechtfertigt zu sein das heißt man
muss die night vorwurf immer darauf
überprüfen ob eher zutrifft oder ob es
andere gründe gibt hier hinter stehen
zum beispiel gerechtigkeitsgründen und
genau das wird meiner meinung nach aber
in öffentlichen debatten nicht gemacht
wenn jemand mit dem neid vor aufkommt
und das macht ihn zu einem
scheinargumente also sie haben gesagt
ich sage meine ich teile das ich finde
auch das ist ein zum guten teil falsches
argument die leute sind gar nicht so
naiv wie das häufig suggeriert wird
und noch einmal wir hatten das schon die
leute vergleichen sich in der regel
nicht mit denen die sehr viel mehr haben
sondern sie vergleichen sich mit dem
namen umfassen das sind dann sozusagen
kleinen aiden wenn man das so sagen kann
es ist nicht diese große leid der dann
so eine möglichkeit gegen die oberen
reichen produzieren würden so etwas gibt
es glaube ich bei uns nicht
es gibt ein anderes argument dass sie
zum beispiel für relevante hatten
nämlich dasjenige der kija dass sie
sagen das problem ist eigentlich gar
nicht so sehr das problem ist die gier
und zwar eine kollektive gier
das haben sie ganz am anfang des
gesprächs ja schon angetönt das problem
ist im grunde genommen dieser
wachstumszwang dass sie alle immer mehr
konsumieren müssen und dass das
eigentlich unser wirtschaftssystem am
laufen hält sie nicken teilen sie das
es kann ja ich denke schon dass das
vorhanden
und auch unter reichen ist das natürlich
zum vergleichen sich natürlich auch sind
irgendwo eingeladen
also ich glaube unser haus ist ja schon
ein bisschen kleine soll im vergleich
jetzt zudem wo wir da eingeladen sind
oder er fährt jetzt noch toller vater
ich glaube ich gehe ich verfahre
nächstes wochenende auch wieder zum
händler
und das meinte ich auch vorhin mit es
ist wichtig dass man zufrieden sein kann
mit dem was man hat und dass es macht
also es gibt auch sehr unzufrieden
reiche die eben immer finden denn ich
möchte nicht auf dieser liste noch
weiter nach oben kommen
jetzt geht ja mehr um diese kollektive
ja sie sagen wir alle sind von der
besamung genau ich glaube das ist auch
etwas was kollektiv vorliegt und
individuell ist das gar keine gier
sondern da ist es so dass man eben ein
bisschen mehr haben möchte dass man eben
sozusagen sich nach oben streckt ja so
ein bisschen nach oben
das ist ja auch ganz normal dass in ganz
vielen kontext wenn man sport macht
möchte man ein bisschen besser werden
aber dann ist man nicht gierig nach
leistung im sport oder sonst ein
bisschen besser wurden aber wir haben
eine gesellschaftsstruktur die davon
lebt dass das bei allen menschen der
fall ist und dass das nie aufhört ja
beim wenn ich joggen gehe dann ist das
ja ein bisschen besser werden möchte
aber es gibt dann irgendwann punkt wo
ich sage ja aber da ist es so dass ich
mich nicht nur meine kinder kümmern
konnte jetzt das wie mache ich das nicht
das heißt gierig zu sein bedeutet andere
relevante normativ wichtige aspekte aus
dem blick zu verlieren
die materie ist nach geld oder nach ehre
der achtet nicht mehr darauf welchen
schaden er vielleicht damit anrichten
könnte und individuell sind die menschen
nicht so die achten sehr genau darauf
wer gerade in der schweiz aber als
gesellschaft tun - nicht das beste
beispiel dafür ist tatsächlich die
entschädigung der klimawandel kann dir
diesen artikel byd sie in der nähe
dieser artikel hat mich echt auch wie
soll ich sagen mir nochmal neuen aspekt
aufgezeigt ist in gordon erschienen im
september 19
und da geht es um diesen einen punkt
nämlich dass im grunde genommen reichtum
strukturell ein problem ist weil wir
sehen dass diejenigen die vermögen sind
auch einfach sehr viel konsumieren egal
wie sie leben sie leben immer auf
größeren fuß
wohnraum größere reisen fliegen mehr
konsumieren mehr und so weiter und
deswegen wäre die idee wir brauchen
einen deckel auf dem reichtum auch
zugunsten des klimas stimmt das das sind
ja dann auch wieder nicht die kleidung
der reichsten einwohner in europa
umfahrung zu ertragen insofern war und
ich gebe ihnen bei dieser normativen
definition von gier gebe ich ihnen recht
dass er kann nicht gut mit leben ich
weiß immer noch nicht genau was es
bedeutet das sollte es wie eine
strukturelle hierbei ist aber wo ich
wirklich mit ihnen im boden ist
wir haben immer eine tendenz aus
individuum das wird sicher
gesellschaftlich unterstützt die
wirklich wichtigen dinge im leben nicht
zu schätzen also wir haben ne tendenz
auf macht reichtum ehre und so weiter
zuschauen und im grunde genommen wissen
wir ganz genau ein gelingendes leben
führt nicht jemand der nur auf diese
dinge setzt die sind ganz wichtig aber
was wirklich im leben zählt das sind
liebevolle beziehung respektvolle
kommunikation und solidarität unter den
menschen
und wenn unser verhalten unseren unser
denken dazu führt dass wir solche dinge
übersehen wenn man das hier nennen will
das nennen wir es hier und das ist
bestimmt etwas was nicht lebens
verträglich ist
aber ich glaube dass das etwas was man
nicht im individuum zu schreiben kann
sondern was tatsächlich gesellschaftlich
gewollt ist und ich glaube sogar dass es
mal eine historische phase gab in der
das eine total kluge idee war nämlich
vor 250 jahren als wir gedacht haben
okay was machen wir dann dass wir dafür
sorgen dass sich die dass die wirtschaft
wächst dass wir ein wirtschaftssystem
schaffen das uns den wohlstand den wir
jetzt in europa haben besorgt und das
war genau diese strukturelle die
orientierung zu sagen wir brauchen ein
wirtschaftssystem das darauf angewiesen
ist dass es immer weiter wachsen muss
weil es sonst implodiert und jetzt haben
wir das problem dass wir das geschaffen
haben und an einem punkt angekommen sind
wo wir eigentlich sagen sie wir haben so
viel das müsste nicht weiter wachsen
aber wir können nicht umstellen wir
können von diesem wirtschaftssystem das
darauf angewiesen ist dass immer mehr
konsumiert werden muss dass immer mehr
produziert werden muss können wir nicht
umstellen auf ein wirtschaftssystem und
das liegt auch daran dass die menschen
individuell
mein kleines bisschen mehr ich würde
ihnen gerne das schlusswort geben frau
stieber sie sind ja an der spitze eines
unternehmens so lange ich darauf
angewiesen dass menschen ihre autos
kaufen wollen
wie reagieren sie auf diese ja das ist
also ich sehe und punkte und das ist
natürlich ein gewisses dilemma also
gerade wenn man autos verkaufen wir alle
eigentlich der meinung sind man sollte
insgesamt weniger auto fahren
und ja aber als unternehmerin bin ich
natürlich auch darauf angewiesen dass es
gibt es die leute unsere produkte kaufen
und ich sehe nur noch nicht wie die
wirtschaft in welche richtung sie sich
ändern könnte und immer noch
funktionieren aber also das problem dass
da haben sie völlig recht dass ich schon
philosophie beginnt oft damit und endet
manchmal auch damit dass wir probleme zu
analysieren versuchen aber die fragen
genau die gehen selbstverständlich
weiter ich muss sagen ich bin neidisch
aus all diejenigen die mehr sendezeit
zur verfügung haben aber ich übe mich
jetzt in bescheidenheit und bedanke mich
sehr für die reichhaltige diskussion
frau stüber hupen bauernhäuser danke
sehr dass sie zu uns gekommen dass im st
nächste woche stehen wir kurz vor
silvester zeit innezuhalten zu fragen
sinnvoll und glücklich leben wie gelingt
es zu gast bei mir ist annemarie pieper
die philosophieprofessorin in basel war
und heute romane schreibt vom 16 bis 18
januar geht das dritte zuger philosophie
festival über die bühne
natürlich sind auch wir mit von der
partie und verlosen 10 x 2 tickets
mit etwas glück und einer mail an
philosophie ab sf punkt ch sind sie
sogar umsonst dabei teilnahmeschluss ist
der fünfte januar jetzt gleich folgt das
porträt des indischen magnum-fotografen
rackerei der persönlichkeiten die mutter
teresa oder den dalai lama vor seiner
linse hatte und durch seine arbeit
selber zum spirituellen meister wurde
jetzt erst einmal frohe festtage und bis
bald
[Musik]